if i'm trying to get my wife to go where
i want to go to dinner because i want to
go to cheesecake factory the finest
establishment in the land if i say hey
babe you want to go to cheesecake
factory she might be like well no i
don't want to go to cheesecake factory
now if i switched that and i said would
you be against going to cheesecake
factory well i'm not against going to
tca faction i'm like great let's go
someone says that they have to talk to
their business partner they have to talk
to their husband or they have to talk to
their wife you say well what would
happen if they said no if they say well
i would do it anyways then boom you
close the sale let's say that for some
reason they say like i left the car that
i that i wanted to use or whatever no
problem do you have a phone on you cool
why don't you pull up your banking app
go to your statements and then we can
see your account number on the top right
and we can write that down we can do an
aca transaction someone says i need to
think about it or i need some more time
to make the decision i say listen it
doesn't take time to make decisions it
takes information and the problem is we
think that the longer we wait the more
information we're going to have but i'm
the only source of information that you
have to make this decision so what are
your main concerns